most people don't spend the time  particularly in the tech world just to  read you know you know the beauty of  tech is that it's changing every minute  of every day and there's really two  classes of people in the tech world the  person or people who invented it and  then there's everybody else and other  than the people who created the  technology everybody else is in the same  boat you know if you just spend the time  to learn whatever it is well you're  competing with people who are having to  do the exact same thing and by reading  the manual by spending investing the  time to to try to get upfront on  technology you can be ahead of the curve  because most people won't put in the  effort